welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and get that dirt out of your eye
because we have a new trailer for
spider-man no way home the hype is out
of control for this film so i am going
to react to this trailer then go through
the big highlights and takeaways that we
learned from it and then i am going to
work through the night on a frame by
frame analysis of all the harder-to-spot
details and clues and easter eggs that
breakdown's coming tomorrow you'll get
your breakdown when you fix this damn
door and thank you to baksu for
sponsoring this video more on them later
but on to the reaction here we go
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
i was wondering that was when you found
out
[Music]
i can't handle this you botched that
spell where you wanted everyone to
forget the peter parker spider-man
we started getting some visitors
yes yes
hello peter
oh man
you're not peter parker
licensed
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so scooby-doo this crap
you know all this is kind of your mess i
know a couple of magic words myself
starting with the word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too
don't
what
oh my god this looks so good
look there has to be another winch there
isn't
there a danger to our universe he is
absorbing the nato tech you're not going
to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling around
damn
everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
god
that statue liberty
[Applause]
show them
bastards what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
you're doing
oh my god
exclusively and moving back to formula
still november 29th
wow okay so this second trailer for
spiderman no way home is giving us a
bigger picture of what exactly the plot
mechanics are for this film it's not
just that peter parker wanted to wish to
gaslight all of society to forget that
he's spider-man and that something went
wrong with that spell it's that the side
effect of that spell brought in all of
these other universe spider-man villains
from the sam raimi films from the mark
webb films and that the stakes for peter
in this mission is that he feels some
sympathy for these characters because
they died fighting alternate versions of
spider-man and he doesn't want to doom
them to their deaths by forcing them to
go back to a flat line what a
fascinating twist for peter parker to
want to save these characters to want to
give them a second chance because that
is essentially what he's going through
he's facing a redemption arc society
thinks he is a villain who killed
mysterio when he didn't kill quentin
beck jake gyllenhaal taylor swift did
that with all too well you know i've
been breaking down these kind of things
for years now and to keep me going i
like to have some snacks within reach
the problem is i've just kind of gotten
tired of the same old snacks i've been
curious about mixing up some snacking
with some new flavors and if you're like
me you should give baksu a try thanks to
boxsu for sponsoring this video baksu is
a monthly subscription service that
delivers premium japanese snacks and tea
pairings straight from japan to your
door each themed monthly boksu box takes
you on a gourmet journey through japan
baksu is the only company that partners
with 100 year old family snack makers
for genuine and authentic selections the
first boxu you will receive is called
seasons of japan look it comes loaded
with snacks here and this booklet that
walks you through it all not to brag but
i have actually been to japan and i had
an incredible trip visiting my brother
and some of these snacks are just really
taking me back
yay
this is the aomori apple caramel cookie
it's made in the apple growing region of
japan and has a soft and chewy texture
that the japanese call yakoi i'm sure
mispronouncing it but i'm not miss
enjoying this cookie you don't get these
kind of flavors from snacks in the u.s
the box food box just makes her a really
cool gift for that anime fan or travel
lover in your life and if you subscribe
before december 31st you will not only
be getting great snack boxes every month
you'll also be entered to win tickets to
japan and i can tell you that is a once
in a lifetime opportunity you won't want
to pass up click the link in the
description and use our code rockstars
to get 10 percent off your subscription
now yes we got no tobey maguire or
andrew garfield in this trailer i'm not
at all surprised there's no way they
would put that in the trailer that would
be a huge twist that would get people to
their feet when they watch this movie
still not confirmed but we all pretty
much expect to see them in this movie
and thank god they didn't show them in a
trailer because why would people need to
go see the movie at that point some
amazing world building that i am excited
about from this trailer looks like the
statue of liberty is being redesigned to
be burying captain america's shield what
a cool honor to the character that might
confirm that the character is actually
dead or at least people think that
they're dead my hope is that they don't
change out lady liberty because that has
its own symbolism to all kinds of people
of course but we did see the statue of
liberty in that shot in avengers end
game of all the boats moored up to the
island to go from that to this
potentially being a beacon of freedom
from tyranny not just from other foreign
oppressors but literally foreign to
earth oppressors as captain america
stood thinking he was all alone facing
thanos in that endgame final battle but
then found out that portal after portal
all of us were on his left in that
battle and what an amazing set piece to
stage the final battle of this movie on
it reminds us a lot of that shot in
spider-man far from home when mysterio
was messing with peter parker's head
peter parker realized he was standing on
a giant captain america's shield
surrounded by toppled statues of his
avengers icons all of that foreshadowing
this final battle where peter parker's
gonna have to fight for the avengers
legacy on a giant captain america shield
also me joking back to formula this
brings us all the way back to the
original formula of the modern era of
marvel movies the first marvel film that
kevin feige worked on the first x-men
film in 2000 which also had its final
battle on the statue of liberty so much
is coming full circle in this film and
i'm pumped for it so last trailer we
really just got docked and then a hint
to green goblin with a pumpkin grenade
this time we see and we hear willem dabo
adds green goblin norman osborne in all
his glory willem dafoe is one of the
greatest working actors alive right now
and i'm so excited to see him come back
into the marvel world and all of these
actors alfred molina jamie foxx rhys
thomas hayden church and any other
villains they might have are so good at
playing sympathetic characters as well
characters who break your heart
characters you don't want to doom to
their deaths we see all of them in this
trailer jamie foxx as elektro charging
up we see the giant looming face of
sandman the form of the lizard and as
many of you speculated i wasn't too sure
about it looks like doc ock's mechanical
arms are going to be compatible with the
nanotech that tony stark designed into
spider-man's iron spider armor thus it's
red coating and it looks like this green
cube is going to be pivotal to saving
the lives of these villains that peter
doesn't want to see die i gotta spend
more time breaking down this shot of
peter strung between two open portals
and then doctor strange lassoes him what
is going on there what we gotta wonder
about now is this little stinger at the
end of the trailer when doctor strange
says they are starting to come through
he's not referring to the sinister six
they're already in the universe based
off of the apparent timeline of this
footage so who else is coming through in
this moment by trying to banish them
back to their realities could doctor
strange have widened the portal to bring
in other threats from universes beyond
that's why it seems like it's inevitable
that toby mcguire and andrew garfield
and potentially even more people could
just flood in from alternate timelines
but to me it sounds like whatever
threats doctor strange is going to face
in multiverse of madness giant nasty
squid threats like schuma gorath and the
other elder gods the mephisto or what
about uh mutants like the sky's the
limit i'll say it is interesting that
these portal bands are now like purple
right before they were golden i think
that color change is gonna be
significant purple of course is the
color of dormammu also the color of
agatha harkness seems to be the color of
the dark dimension or dark magic in the
mcu but the fact that this is in the
skyline going behind the buildings on
the horizon make it seem like this is
just in the atmosphere of the planet
that the entire world is just gonna get
broken or extracted or transported in
some way ah there are just so many
harder to see details in throughout this
trailer i know it so now i gotta shift
over to combing through this frame by
frame i got a long night ahead of me and
our editors will be working their asses
off overnight as well so that in-depth
breakdown is coming to the trailer
tomorrow when you fix your door don't
come at me scream in rent i don't have
time for it by the way you can support
this channel by checking out our merch
at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea vos follow
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis and breakdowns of
everything marvel thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you